hey everybody and welcome to engagement
is the new black I said my name is Nico
I'm a beedi manager for Google Play
based out in Berlin looking after
Germany Benelux markets and so on later
during this presentation I will be
joined by the great Marcus fart from the
cool app life some to share some
first-hand experience on the topic as
well so probably when you read this
title and even now you like why is
engage with the new black what's up with
the title so let me quickly give you an
introduction to where we are coming from
last year at playtime in London actually
my colleague Matteo did a wonderful talk
on what app developers can learn from
games I'm pretty sure a couple of guys
were here and saw that quick show of
hands okay that's a good 50 percent
awesome so that talk was super well
received and as a follow-up to that we
actually run a second event which was a
workshop completely on onboarding on
conversion which we ran I think in
February in our London office with
partners from the UK but also all over
from Europe
anybody that attended this workshop in
the audience cool
so one of the main things that was
discussed in this workshop was one very
obvious one that obviously you all you
do like this on this on board onboarding
and conversion is in order to get
lifetime value outperforming the cost
per install right it's an obvious one
and then when you looked into lifetime
value and that's one thing that really
resonated with a lot of the people it
really depends on three things heavily
that is engage retention engagement in
monetization I'm not going to go too
much into monetization because we have a
full session on that just after this
today it's going to talk about talk
about all about this but I really want
to focus on retention engagement because
it's such an important driver to your
business and the question that came out
of the crowd really I aligned this so
therefore for me this is really the new
black and it's really interesting to see
the conversation I've been having over
the last couple years in this job has
shifted from Oh have that many downloads
to have that many installs to over
really do this to really engage a user
so it's quite a key topic before we do
that there is one thing that's kind of
the antagonist of retention engagement
can anybody guess what that is its churn
right the users that are not engaged in
there are not retained is that users
that are churning so I very quickly want
to take a deeper look into what churn
actually means before we move on into
the next session where I want to show
some ways we're so easy fixes on how to
actually engage and retain your users
before we get Marcus on stage and share
some of the insights they have so let's
face it churn really happens to the best
of us it doesn't really matter I mean it
doesn't matter but even if you build the
greatest product out there even if
you're in one of the top 10 developers
on the place your most successful you
will still lose a lot of you like good
portion of your users and I think that's
natural it's part of any business to
customer relationship not only apps work
but in basically any any business and
there are some common things that we see
in actually our industry why that is so
let's face them let's name them what are
some common reasons for churn and I
would really appreciate if you helped me
there because there are many any ideas
just the other marked out
awesome yeah boring another one so I
tried to come up with as many as I could
find
number one usually is pro technical
quality and if you saw the lounge
presentation this morning it was
actually mentioned that really low
ratings often caused by technical
stability number two was actually
spot-on its insufficient value
proposition so the product is just not
there or it's not good enough the third
one is maybe the product is good enough
but you're not making it clear to the
user so it's not they don't really know
how great your product is or you're just
not fresh enough the content is outdated
the functionality is our data you're not
keeping pace with the market or it's not
personalized enough it's too
interchangeable right it's great but
others do it as well and the user you
know they like to try new things so they
go to something else and then why they
should be coming back and I think that's
a classic
you just overdo it on push notifications
or general communication that's a
classic one as well and many many more
that I think cost problems and they
cause you guys headaches and I know this
from the various conversations I have
with my partners and we have as a team
with partners however what I person he
really really loved about this industry
is that you guys never stay with oh this
is the problem it's always about oh wow
this is the problem and it's also an
opportunity right like how can we
actually use these things and turn them
around into something better and what I
really learned I love about my job at
Google Play is that I work with so many
interesting and forward-thinking
partners and that I actually have the
chance to see all these different
tactics and fixes and so on they use in
order to retain and engage users and
what I want to do now is share some of
the knowledge we have gained in that
topic back to you guys
so here's a list of about seven common
themes that I personally think and I
learned from various conversations and
meetings and also preparing this topic
that you simply cannot ignore if you
want to retain and engage your users
you'll receive your slides more often so
if you don't manage to take this the
photo just now it'll come back one short
disclaimer on this it's by no means an
exclusive list there are many many ways
or many things that could be added to
this and if you really feel like there's
something missing what we should
investigate another bullet or even if
you think something is not right on this
list I'm very very much looking forward
to your feedback and I encourage you
just like everybody else to have that
conversation with me with anybody in the
room and keep the conversation going and
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
go through each of them in a bit more
detail and I would invite you to not
only listen to me but also to kind of
actively go through your product and
think about how you dealing with these
different things and you'll probably
find that being leading developers
you're doing a great job and many of
them already but first of all there's
always room for improvement no matter
how good it is and second of all also
keep in mind that maybe you are very
much aware of all these things but maybe
within your company that's something you
can spread more and engage more
colleagues on this so first things first
let's talk about the importance of
having a good value proposition I don't
know it seems super super obvious and it
has been mentioned throughout various
talks that I've seen today but it's just
really really important to have it clear
to have it to have that crystal clear
and here are some things or some
questions that I think you need to have
the right answers to and again it's not
necessarily only you having the right
answers too but also make sure these
answers are known across the various
teams and across the company so first of
all what is your USP
it could be many different things
depending on which vertical urine if
you're a publisher and you store you
publish news or stories then the quality
of the story could be one of your
selling propositions if you're a fitness
app it could be that your motivate your
users very well to actually exercise
more and so on that I think is the most
important bit but also keep in mind that
your users are usually not one
homogeneous group but there are
different user cohorts so there may well
be more than one USP that is really
important for your business the second
one is what does engagement mean for you
and it's trivial as that question sounds
really think hardly about what is it
that you want the user to do that
actually makes them fall in love with
your product
and come back and actually start
building this relationship with you as a
developer or as a product offering and
third one it kind of goes along with
number one and two what are the
corresponding KPIs like whenever we have
where I have conversations with partners
and I think that's probably the same
when you have conversations among each
other you compare a lot of KPIs but it's
not necessarily that the same KPIs are
as relevant for for everybody in the
room right if you let's say a document
storage app and that really helps me
secure all my important documents then
actually retaining me over a year and
having these login once a year maybe a
super important KPI well if you build a
social app on the other hand you want to
look into sessions per day that I
generate right so be really aware of
what KPIs are important to you
number two is again I think it's
somewhat obvious one but I want to give
you a certain angle to it it's to fully
utilize the potential of the Android
platform and in the talks this morning
again we heard a lot from mark and from
Ellie and Yellen and so on like how much
we're investing in making sure that the
platform grows it gives you more more
opportunities however
doing this is also a great way or a
great tool for engagement and retention
in one of many great examples we video
it's a actually a video editing app they
change the whole UX to material design
and we're able to increase user
engagement by 100 percent from doing
that just because the experience became
so seamless and understandable and
grateful users and it goes beyond that
adopting stuff like Android auto Android
TV or Android wear can also make a huge
difference on how you engage your users
with your app so another question for
you guys
are there any golf players in the
audience any golf players there is one
this is you this is there's another one
I thought this is a great Brittan you
know if it's here two comments for
anyways so if you're into golf you may
actually know a whole nineteen it's an
app I think it was also featured in the
opening video today you saw actually
people playing golf so you might be
familiar with it from that it's a it's
an app that lets you gives you all the
distances and GPS data on golf course I
think they have about 40,000 golf
courses in the world mapped out let's
see do digital scorecards track your
scores and then obviously share them
with your other golfing buddies they
brought their app to Google where and
what they saw is a 40 percent increase
in monthly active users with Android
we're actually bringing some of the most
engaging with us all of them they
actually go as far that they tend to
call themselves or they tend to call the
app where first app and it makes a lot
of sense think about it you're on the go
of course you just hit a birdie or a
hole-in-one or whatever it is and you
want to track it it's much more
convenient to like do it on your watch
and on your wrist then getting out your
phone and logging into the app so
another great way to engage and retain
your users um moving on to the third fix
or tactic and that's probably my
personal favorite making user onboarding
grades and it also came out of the Q&A
for
from peak what is probably the most
important thing for engaging users is
user onboarding it's not only my
favorite topic also of my favorite
analogy for it
first-time user onboarding is like a
first date so basically you get all the
excitement you get the full undivided
attention and you can ask all the
questions in the world that you want to
want to learn about the preferences from
the other from your user or from your
date you do all this with only one goal
in mind to get another date and then
hopefully another date another date and
turn this into a long lasting
relationship but with all that we also
know I'm sorry too fast that it's a
tricky it's tricky because there's also
so much room for it to go wrong so what
I want to try to do on the next slide is
give you some very simple guidelines of
things you should keep in mind when you
build your own boarding and again like
go through your onboarding along these
points and see if you actually meet the
full amount of points on all these so
the first one is there should be fast
and seamless right nothing more annoying
if it really takes forever when I just
want to get to the to the actual stuff
in the app the second it should be
contextual and it should be part of the
product experience I think that is
something that I still see so many
partners not you know getting to a full
capacity or doing as good as they can
and I'll show you an example of what I
mean and the third is asking users for
minimal user input while on the other
hand gathering all the information you
need to actually create a great
engagement and I think that's the tricky
bit because it's always a very fine line
you're walking on one fantastic example
we see we have featured before I think
is the fitness app freeletics so
freeletics when you open it up it really
what I really like about it it really
immerses you in the product world right
you get to this screen shot you're like
you think the training
has already started even though you
don't you don't know what's coming for
you when you're then actually trained I
just want to say that so they really
immerse you in that product experience
and take credit for different user
cohorts basically you get to the second
screen you select if you're male or
female and depending on that the
tonality and the screenshots and the
onboarding really changes Oh other way
around now this used to be animated so
basically if you're a man after this the
imagery goes into that tonality as well
also what they have done is they
integrated with google smart lock so now
when I get it user new device and I log
into freeletics they automatically sign
me in so they basically remove all the
friction for me to become a sign-in user
and get that user experience right where
it left off a very quick run-through of
what Google smuggler can do and from
left to right that is the experience a
new user has the news II already stirs
the click to register they select an
email address it could be any address
that they have saved with Android or
Chrome then smartlock fills in the gaps
obviously outside of the password the
user gets to choose it themselves
they're logged in and then on the last
screen they can decide if they want to
save the password to smart lock and
actually we see over like across all the
apps we see I think 65% of users
actually saving their passwords and then
they're in that system that makes it
really easy for them we also have two
really cool case studies on that which I
just going to talk about the not on this
slide but Kumud which is an outdoor
activity app that didn't a be test where
they tested Google smart log as a
sign-in versus another sign in and they
had a 90 percent increase in sign up
conversion with smart lock and the
second one is solando which is a
shopping app that see 20% of the current
signing events are automatic buy smart
lock so if you want if this is one of
your aims and I think most partners do
really push for getting users logged in
then this is
definitely something to consider for you
as I said onboarding is not only
important it's not my favorite topic is
also super important so with all super
important things in your app you should
test test and test again right and it's
a rate and test again and one of the
another two that I want to show you for
that is firebase remote config and that
lets you run a be experiments and it
lets the custom control key values
within your app and the change and all
everything you change basically goes
live instantly so if you're familiar
with the over firebase suite that's
another handy tool to look into to
actually optimize the onboarding
workflow or also any other part in your
app quite frankly so quick recap and
before I move into the next one
we're number four now the first one was
having a clear value proposition second
one leveraging the full Android platform
third one make great user onboarding and
number four is actually about
successfully release a new feature and I
call it the kind of younger sister or
younger brother of user onboarding
because there's so many similarities in
how to think about it first of all and
you remember from this slide on reasons
to churn is you got to stay fresh right
and you guys know this you're leading
developers in your industry you know
there's somebody coming for you
essentially and you got to move ahead of
the curve you've got to come up with new
features if you're about content you got
it you got constantly need to push new
content in order to stay relevant to
users so that's a very general advice on
that which I think you most of you are
familiar with and when you do introduce
new features or content what I think is
a very simple and systematic relief
methodology to film to follow is to
first of all test that with beta users
that was mentioned before to make sure
that it actually works on retention
engagement metrics secondly again in
short technical stability thirdly really
show users what's new and that's
actually what the screenshot here is for
imagine you have never seen this product
you were introduced to this and you
could actually navigate from here if you
drive in your car and there are some
very easy ways with material design to
make this visually very simple in
lightweight but yet very clear to users
when they own bought you a new feature
and then as a fourth point obviously
analyze the performance again we have a
couple of tools that are super useful
for that and for point number one and
two at beater groups and pre-launch
reports both were featured in large this
morning I'm not going to go into them I
just want to give it a big fat plus 1 or
plus 2 depending on how you want to see
it and on pre-launch reports actually
keep in mind that you need to opt in and
so it's not going to happen
automatically so you need to go in the
console opt-in for to be activated and
then every single thing you upload to
alpha beta actually runs these checks
and then use cohort analysis in firebase
analytics or in Google Analytics to
really check the performance of new
features alright it's one thing that you
build something new and fancy and cool
but you really want to make sure that
you actually optimize against that goal
for retention or engagement that you
have and as always numbers is the best
way to make a decision another point you
may recall from the list we showed of
reasons why users churn is that your app
or an app may be true interchangeable
and what with what the competitor is
offering one really cool way to counter
this is to personalizing the experience
so to make the user feel at home and I
think there are two main way of doing
this number one is where you basically
give the user all kinds of manual ways
to design the experience right you may
like let them toggle and stuff in the
home screen switch stuff on and off and
so on and I think all of that is great
just what I think happens quite a lot of
what we hear happens quite a lot that
that really remains something that
mostly power users do and it's really
hard to get like average of the broad
range of users actually to do that
so another way to do this is by actually
doing personalization by using business
intelligence and to individualize the
product experience and I will show you
what that means am a great example for
this that was shared with me actually
was from hotels calm they use they
basically anticipate user or they use
user behavior to anticipate users needs
and provide the relevant experience in
the right moment so what does I mean
they try to map various scenarios for
users coming into the app one is one
boarding when it's about one boarding
they try to make it as convenient as
possible for the user to actually go to
sign in when a user actually comes back
to the app so it's a returning user has
searched before and they may show them
something that's relevant to the search
of where they were left off and then
another scenario could be that somebody
has actually booked a hotel with hotels
calm and on the day of check in or check
out they will provide relevant
information maybe around where people
travel or stuff around the hotel and
information so there's different
scenarios are where the user really
feels like this is a personalized
experience to them how they do that is
first of all by you know being aware of
all of that and actually caring caring
and catering for it but also by creating
a flexible content structure that
actually allows them to move around
content and modules to react to this
broad range of scenarios and then the
third one is that they actually
exhaustively map the context instead of
content or action the user was left in
so that when you leave and you come back
you really feel like you continue where
you left off so I think that's a great
example of using data and a
sophisticated technical approach to
actually provide personal user
experience for a broad range and you
know some of you may probably think now
oh you said easy fixes this seems very
complex yes this is probably one of the
things that are not that straightforward
an easy to set up but once you have it
it's actually a very neat way to to you
do that personalization so I think it's
really worth the effort of looking into
that the second last I want to talk
about is having a great communication
strategy and it ties very much into the
personalization bit so push
notifications is what I'm going to focus
on and they have become somewhat the
standard on the platform and as an
engagement tool and rightfully so right
they work great if you do a great job on
them however there's also a fine line
between using them to drive engagement
on the one hand or to actually make
users churn because you're overdoing it
or they're not relevant or whatever it
may be
so again so very simple rules in order
to make that strategy successful first
the push notification needs to be
relevant so the context the language the
tonality and needs to be relevant to the
user and be creative might be true to
your brand be creative speak to the
customer in a unique way I think that's
something that I still see a lot of
partners not fully fully optimizing
second needs to be actionable is it an
FYI is it actually a call to action do
you want me to do something if so and
then make sure that is deeply and I want
to actually click through I get to
whatever you talked about because that's
not happen then the user experience is
really burning you're like okay why
where am i why am I here and you're
probably not going to do it again or
you're less likely to push on and
opening the app again and then third one
is I want to talk about timeliness first
timeliness the right message at the
right time again seems very obvious but
I think the London Olympic on a deal on
and sorry the Rio Olympics were a great
example of that and a lot of the stuff
happen overnight for users in amia so
the question becomes is it that Usain
Bolt won 100 meters or somebody broke a
world record is that really more
relevant at 3m in the morning on a
Tuesday night or should you be waiting
to push that message at 7:00 a.m. in the
morning when you know you users get up
and they actually check their news right
so there are things to keep in mind and
not only go oh this is a great thing
I'll just push it out because
may lose its effect on users first of
and then the fourth point is
personalization and you should segment
users you should have your cohorts and
then also dry proactively let you just
opt-out of stuff and up into other stuff
especially the opt-out part seems
counterintuitive but let me give you one
great example where what you see on the
Left actually this is a screenshot of
Aftenposten it's a it's a huge one of
the biggest newspapers in the Nordics
and they basically a while ago they
redid the whole kind of notice on
boarding and as part of that the new
notification management screen and they
showed some fantastic results so
basically now when you onboard
you just get to select - I think this is
pre-selected and then they get to opt
out but the proactively asked to do so
em so what they saw is first of all that
I think over 50% of the users actually
keep two of the three right to the take
one off consciously but they take the
other ones because they think they're
relevant and then overall they saw a
decrease of uninstalls by I think nine
percent over sixty days which i think is
a strong argument for the point I tried
to make earlier were too many push
notifications or not having a strategy
can be really be something that leads to
churn while it should be really
something that helps you engage and
retain users and then also another
interesting side effect is that they
really learned about the users and the
preferences of those users and to my
surprise apparently there were less
users interested in sports and then in
the other topics for me usually that's
exactly the other way around em again
just to highlight one tool that you can
use for that very well is fire by Klaus
met fire bait fire based cloud messaging
and let your target individual devices
quotes and so on super reliable and it's
cross-platform it doesn't only work for
Android so you can you can use it across
the platforms web and iOS as well last
but not least rewarding user engagements
and let's talk a bit about that
I think very generally this should be
something everybody should be thinking
about from the perspective of making it
really desirable for you to become for
your users to become an engaged user
with you and when they are engaged user
really reward them and show you that you
value that um obviously it's a topic and
this is something I realized more than
ever when I started researching it for
this talk that you can go really deep in
when it comes to like gamification and
the mechanics around it and so on right
and there are many great strategies and
I've probably with a lot of the gaming
guys here they could go on about this
for lengthen and without any end however
it can already start with very simple
rewards mechanism right there's a it's a
broad range it's a lot large spectrum of
stuff you can do and what works for your
app really depends on on your app on
your industry if you have what business
model you have a freemium premium and so
on however if you just wanna if you're
not doing anything at all and I think
you should then you can start with
keeping a very simple thinking of
something that adds value to your users
and makes sense and fits with your
overlap ecosystem so a couple of good
examples are inviting power users to
early access to test beta features and
so on give them a special preview right
it's a very simple one but you you
wouldn't believe how many users really
love that and I do it for a lot of the
products that I love to work proactively
tell the developer please like include
me like product testing just because I
love the product so much and the second
one are badges right how do I know that
because you guys all love it whenever
it's about a badge on Google Play people
go crazy top developer badge and editors
choice and so on and usually the ones
that go most crazy are the deaths right
maybe sometimes the business people we
talk to they're like what's the impact
was that they talked about all these
numbers and then we talk about that but
then when they get it it's only all my
android developers freaked out we like
best of that we're part of here right so
really giving this simple bet it doesn't
usually it doesn't cost you anything it
just needs
you need to come up with the structure
how to do it and you can really show
users how value they are and then you
can do stuff like offering up exclusive
discounts generally the more you can
individual individualize that the better
but again starting off with a very broad
range and basically just showing you is
that you value that they are there and
go from there is a really good start the
bottom line is these engage users are
your best customer and they should be
valued because who does not like to be
valued so here the seven fixes again in
an overview and I think you had enough
for me for now this was quite a lot of
input I think so it's time for some
first-hand experience and I would like
to welcome Marcus Fogg from lifestyle up
on stage I'm gonna go so now I feel very
gamified around the badges things cool
so I guess a lot of you probably think
that I'm here to present the secrets
around the holy grail of retention if I
happen to do something like that please
feel free to share that with me that
would be some fantastic knowledge to
have no so but as Nico said I'm Marcus
I'm from lie some and I think that
retention and engagement is probably the
most the most interesting topic because
it basically tells you like how good is
your product I mean if your users are
coming back it's a good product so
that's the one metric that should be
above everyone else I think so so just
going to give you sort of a bit of an
insight around how we think around
retention at like some and engagement so
starting off with a little bit about us
but also what retention engagement means
to health in specific then a little bit
of what we track and why we track it and
then I have two examples one will be
tested and fail miserably and the other
one where we tested and actually
succeeded it's nice that you can set up
this a gambler because then it makes it
looks like it's a 50/50 split there
which might not always be the case
and then I'm running up with a few sort
of take aways so start with a bit about
us I think three few things within
health that needs to be fixed so today
health care is actually a lot about sick
care it's like you wait until you get
sick and then you get treated but
instead it should be that you do a lot
of stuff with your lifestyle before you
actually get sick I mean the way you eat
how you train exercise how you sleep
stress levels etcetera will affect your
life so that's basically what we are
here for we are here to sort of help
help you with that but then when we talk
about engagement and retention I think
it's kind of interesting when it comes
to health because no one has really sold
it in a good way and I don't think
that's all about like just health apps I
think it's for the health sector in
general so let's take gyms for example I
think in the u.s. you have about 70% of
people that own a gym subscription isn't
going to the gym and you have like when
it goes with medication or medical and
pharma about 50% of people are on
medication isn't taking them properly so
the challenge is like how do you get
people to think it's like interesting
and fun to take care of themselves which
is hard and well of course within this
sort of industry you can be there either
good or you can be bad at this and I
think the live Sun is we're not we're
not the worst with definitely not not
the best either but for us it's like
it's definitely the number one company
goal is to work with retention it's this
is the stuff that we talk about every
day it's definitely the key for us so we
haven't figured out what we are trying
to do a lot of stuff around it so little
bit about what we track and why we track
it so we have a few standard metrics
that we follow on a daily basis so we
look at seven-day retention we look at
week five retention and look at week 53
retention so of course we do our deep
dives etc within those with these are
the ones that are standard so what we
know this was that when the user is
coming to the live some app a lot of
them hasn't actually decided that they
want to change something with their
lives they want to become healthier so
they're super engaged in that very first
moment when they come into the app but
then what we've seen is that they
rapidly drop
during the first seven days so for us
the number one metric to follow has been
the seven-day metric but then most
recently we've started to think a little
bit different around retention that you
shouldn't really treat it the same way
for all users because it's kind of
different depending on what you want to
achieve so we looked at the data and we
see that we have basically like four
different types of users the master
defocused
the dieter and the long term and named
them so let's let's take the dieter for
example you have like in the US the
average American goes on a diet about
four times a year which is quite a lot
it's crazy I know
and that diet will last from anywhere
between a few days to a few weeks so for
us then it's important so instead of
trying to force the dieters behavior to
become the master which is like tracking
every day for several months we should
just recognize okay this person is on a
diet we need to make the app as good as
possible for them to come back for the
next diet so hot rods that sort of
thinking like okay if we can put these
people in different buckets we should
treat them differently so two examples
we'll start with with a sad one so we
have this yeah well as knowledge about
the users are very motivated in their
first disk so we thought that if we can
get them to invest a lot of time and
energy in the app at first they will be
coming back so we basically created this
massive health test of 41 questions we
brought in consultants nutritionists etc
we built it into the onboarding flow we
put it on the profile page we prompted
it several times it was a massive
project it took us months to develop and
and then when we released it of course
we were super excited like this is going
to have a massive impact on seven-day
attention and while everyone's just
waiting for the data and when it came
was like it was the sound of no hands
clapping like nothing happened so of
course it wasn't it was it was a big
failure but then of course with failures
usually get some stuff out of it for us
suppose I think first we managed to
confirm
we have very high initial motivation so
are other people starting the test we
had about 90 percent completing all 41
questions so within a few weeks we had
like a million of these test results and
that data is kind of valuable so I mean
first of all it's infinite you can see
like okay how many percent is vegetarian
in London compared to Stockholm for
example but also referring to the
buckets that I talked about we can
actually profile users now based on this
data so it's something that you're not
doing it yet that the way we should be
doing it but it's a really interesting
source but of course from a retention
perspective it wasn't it wasn't good and
I think what we learned from that is
also what the guys have been talking
about before is that I mean you need to
find ways of testing stuff before you
put a lot of effort into it so what
would the oxygens does did stops that
was working out so if you going back a
few months we didn't really have any
sort of social interaction in the app
and I think the reason for that was that
we didn't really know what people wanted
to share because when it comes to your
personal health especially around weight
loss it's not that you want to like oh
this is you don't want to share
everything on Facebook let's put it away
so what we did here is that we created
this very small intimate social feature
like very simple and we ran a test in
Sweden so it's basically that you could
invite up to five friends to become your
sort of team and within that team you
could basically push each other and
motivate each other
you could also remind people if they
were dropping off so um when we got that
out we saw that people on social
actually had a 2x increase in seven-day
retention which was of course fantastic
I mean but if you think about it's like
if you have if you have five people and
three of them drop off and they have two
more that can keep reminding them that's
always going to be better than if you
have like five cielos where no one can
talk so from that perspective it was
really good what we had some issues with
here was though the adoption rate like
we didn't really got that many users to
be on social so we pop the survey for
them that would decline and the
we'll still like a privacy I don't want
to share my data so this is this is
still a big challenge for us to try to
figure out but also massive potential
so yeah wrapping up a little bit I think
I mean looking at your own users
retention is interesting so not just
like treating retention the same way
across different apps or even across
your own users to try to find like what
are your patterns for us it might be
very high initial motivation or that we
have lot of dieters in there but it
might be different for you and then
social is key I mean if you can get your
own users to help you with retention
that is it's always going to be be good
and then also that like referring to the
health test that we did and I think that
everyone is saying this but it needs to
be said over and over again is that you
try you need to find easy quick ways of
testing radius before you spend hundreds
and thousands of billing them cool so
yeah back to Niko to sort of wrap it up
a bit
thank you
yeah so it's great to see that a lot of
the points resonated with you at least
that's a start and so very quickly I
know you guys are waiting for another
coffee break that's what I think is
happening after this and before we do
that I want to go back on the one
summary slide this is actually dr. e he
is obviously for engagement and this is
his checklist that he uses to go through
his apps so I encourage you to take this
list take a screenshot or actually take
it later from YouTube and take it home
with you go through it with your teams
and see what are the things you're doing
what are the things you're doing good
what other things are doing great and
wherever you are not great really think
about how you can actually get there so
we hope this was useful for you guys
thank you very much
you